if we get the baby named before five
o'clock we'll share it with you if not
got it as yet but really looking forward
to finding out what the baby will be
called in fact I think think I might
just have it let's have a quick look the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex are pleased
to announce they have named their child
Archie Harrison mountbatten-windsor so
Archie Harrison mountbatten-windsor that
is the name of the Royal babies we were
all massively wrong as usual but there
he is
Archie Harrison mountbatten-windsor he
has been named we've received that name
within the last few moments so all of
those people that were betting on
Alexander you've done your money along
with lots of other names as well
Archie great name Harrison
mountbatten-windsor this was the moment
that he was introduced to the world a
little bit earlier on today just after
lunchtime
he's as you can see both parents
absolutely thrilled with their bundle of
joy that was born at half-past five or
there abouts 5:26 a.m. on Monday morning
the Bank Holiday Monday very soon after
that we heard from dad who was thrilled
to pieces to tell the world about how
amazing his wife was and how thrilled he
was to be a new daddy even thanked the
horses that were behind him while he was
taking part in that news conference an
impromptu news conference here at
Windsor this was in said George's Hall a
little bit earlier on today just three
and a half minutes or thereabouts they
both told us how thrilled they were with
the new baby how he was as good as gold
dad joked about how he's still got a
little bit of facial hair how he had
been advised that the baby will change
so much during the next two weeks
grandma in the form of Doria who is at
Megan's mum is on hand to help at least
in the short term and we do believe that
Archie Harrison was introduced to her
majesty
Queen she's his her 8th great-grandchild
just a little bit earlier on today along
with the Duke of Edinburgh he is the
latest addition to the royal family